yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is a non blitz game video this
video I'm going to try to solve a couple
of yeah more sophisticated chess puzzles
never should have puzzles really the
right word it's more like yeah the
analysis of a particularly interesting
position and trying to find out what the
best solution is the puzzle I think is
more of a tactical technical thing now
um I wanted to use a book I don't even
have it here a new book that is written
under Mark Trotsky's name Gretzky of
course is dead for three years now it's
a new book probably some of the puzzles
or some of them exercises that was still
open and never used in books but that
book actually um it's a volume seven of
a series it doesn't really have puzzles
in them it doesn't have exercises so
much so I mean doing it differently I'm
using one of the our guide books a
strategic playbook and I just found out
that there are chapters in there one is
called prophylaxis so prophylactic play
trying to yeah make sure that the
opponents play is not hitting you while
you still develop your own ideas this is
prophylaxis and I think it's a very
important part of chess to try to be
aware what the opponent wants to do and
at the same time not forgetting about
your own ideas if you only react to what
they do you're playing passive chess
that's not good but you want to develop
your own game still looking at what they
want to do this is the perfect
combination now this is a good subject
and they have 23 exercise positions here
as far as I see FF had a quick glance I
have never used them in chest training
surprisingly and therefore I don't
really need to randomly choose one I'm
just going for the first one here I'm a
game must love ski star hoviak yes I
have to set up the position
shipped empty editor here this is
someone I wanted to clear bored so I'm
going to set the position up I mean okay
now that I see that I have not used any
of them I could have prepared the
positions but yeah it's not a big deal
let's just set them up
so it looks like some sort of Queen's
Gambit or Queen's Indian structure both
sides still have all their pieces and
looks fairly complex
nights also
Cave and queens on their starting
squares yes that is the position I think
let me check rooks correct
yeah and we have lucky to play
and orientation Lakha thicknesses better
to do and let's create the position I
just have to check again that I'm not
doing something really stupid here
looking at the wrong position happened
too often
okay I think this is correct and we have
to find move for black so what did black
misses the whole react played I played
him once actually in a tournament game
in a 2015 and I played a tournament in
Bratislava anyway so it's black to play
and we should get a grasp of this
position so we have a position where
very importantly the pawn structure is
not very symmetrical black has a form
for pawns against three majority on the
Queen side so and we already have the C
pawn it's the pawn that defines this
majority this is a pawn that still
exists on our hand or not on whites and
this is already advanced and basically
what black wants to do in this position
long term is to push all the pawns
forward get a passed pawn and promote it
just very roughly this is the idea um on
the other hand why it has a majority on
the King side which you can count as
four against three like this or you can
also count if you want five against four
this is also how I sometimes do it it's
a fiber chain against for warp piece or
for poorer chain so what vice general
ideas in terms of pawns is to play f3
and deform and get the central majority
going and also possibly go for an attack
on the king this is of course a very
important point if we advance our pawns
this is nice but we're not going to mate
white
yeah if white manages f3 e4 e5 whatever
yeah push everything forward we could
easily be steamrolled here and get
checkmated so we have a little bit of
help of course as the topic here is
prophylaxis this could mean that white
is actually threatening something yeah
and this is the thing that we have to
find out now what is what is white
possibly threatening
should we do also what is our plan our
plan certainly is to push on the
queenside so the most obvious move here
is certainly the move b5 I think this is
the move that I would probably play if
I'm in a blitz game and just have to
make a quick decision and I'm probably
just playing b5 that also would free up
the night should be six and so on this
is a very obvious move in this position
the question is however if it is the
best move if we have whether we have
something better something that is also
more maybe and the topic gives it away
more prophylactic so what is why it's
IDM
f 3e form it would be really good if we
could stop that
don't quite see though
f 3e for indisposition
this is a really important part of this
position that black has played c4 with
the pawn on c4 there is no pressure on
deform and this would actually make f 3e
form more difficult to play so we see
four black already has decided that he's
going for it on the queenside and makes
it easier for white to push his central
pawn break so we definitely need to find
some good idea there
I think that b5 still looks like a very
natural move awesome it would pre
prepare before with all which also
lessens the control over a four so I can
put this on the board let's say b5 a3
and now the question is whether we're
going to play before Knight b6 the
general idea said after before the
knight now has to go to a four or a two
let's say you two just for argument's
sake now we are on e4 quite a bit three
pieces one pawn two pieces on that
Square and it's difficult for white to
make this happen
this is another important point of b5
that we actually plan to ya increase our
influence on the center hmm
so my real problem is why would be five
not be good it says something else
one point is of course that our d5 pawn
could become vulnerable that is possible
so let's say for example b5 and Queen f3
just trying to snatch this pawn but we
have Knight b6
it looks so fine from him looks fine
find Fanta me hmm so what is wrong about
b5 maybe this just b5 hmm
yeah but this is not the kind of thing
you expect um an exercise that the most
obvious move would be the correct one is
checking that I'm really here does it's
correctly set up hmm this might have
something else that maybe we are not
attending with b5
hmmm I don't see it I already don't see
it
or maybe maybe some Quincy - idea what
I'm talking about is this b5 Quincy to
be 495 just just to show one idea here
now I can take and why takes and takes
and made yeah so this could be something
too
- OH - to think about that Quincy to
possibly threaten this tactic on d5 but
I can also play Knight b6 here and I
don't seek Knight age 5 or Bishop age or
Bishop age 4 that could be a bit of a
problem
yeah I cannot play g6 obviously that can
be taken
and g5 night h5 also looks
bad
White's idea is always to get this son
and maybe it Queen c2 where maybe this
is an idea
ah okay so interesting we found
something at least an idea yeah and this
is what this is also is also about this
this whole video I mean this whole
approach just discussing positions and
scene turns into trying to find yeah
approaches to positions yeah this is
interesting it's not so easy here now it
takes t 5 is a bit of a threat
huh maybe I have to really pay attention
to the Quincy to idea but how how
exactly do I do that
one point is also I think that is
important it is pretty difficult form
white prevent our b5 before advance he
might play a four but we can always play
Bishop c6 and then b5 it's it's it is
almost unstoppable long long term yeah
like even I mean we haven't even made a
move yet for black but if we just assume
we will play something else then b5 I'm
suggesting this one just to look at it
move if then a for trying to stop b5 I
think we can still play Bishop c6 and
prepare this and next moves will be 5 or
b3 b5 I think we will always get this in
so maybe this idea of Quincy tool is
something that we have to look at more
one way of dealing with this could be to
play this music ei that I just mentioned
as a yeah more of a waiting move because
this allows night f8 which would clearly
stabilize the whole situation and would
make Quincy to look actually a bit silly
cannot silly silly is wrong but if now
white goes Quincy to night f8 would be a
very safe on the side of the board yeah
the night on f8 is covering this as well
and this is almost impossible impossible
to challenge it is a purely defensive
piece but if we can stop a battery like
that of you if you do basically piece
counts there we have the Queen equaling
like 10 points and the bishop equally
equaling 3 point something and just one
night is is basically a good absorbing
the energy of this big battery this
wouldn't be a big big problem and we
still can play the b5 stuff also not so
easy to play you for still beyond that
quite a bit and maybe rupee eight could
be a good prophylactic move in order to
play Knight f8 this is however a really
deep concept and I'm wondering if this
is what was intended here
as the solution
let's think about one thing a little bit
more what else could be a threat
Quincy - that's so interesting laughs
really an idea
mmm still just just check this here
Knight b6 and then Bishop H form this is
really a bit of an annoyance g5 doesn't
work g6 doesn't work and yeah I mean you
can argue that this is not made
immediately but it doesn't look right I
mean absolutely not
who
yeah maybe black doesn't lose
immediately
you habit
one this
YUM any other ideas white could go b3
but we always have b5 that is not going
to be a problem I only see these ideas
Quincy to the pawn roller is very slow
anyway and in fact if we play something
like rook e8 f3 it's not something that
would concern me much
I can always now put some pressure on
there pawn for example even with the
bishop here and then still Knight f8 if
necessary mmm okay
unlike rupee 8 as a potential
prophylaxis again the Quincy 2 idea
well okay I'm going to check what the
solution is right
one chef spent more time and the
solution is rook e8 rook e8 b5 is not
good because of Quincy - Wow I got that
right that is nice
so Quincy to
okay I got them I took I got this right
this is good Bishop age fine black
cannot defend his position exactly even
though I thought rookie it wasn't so
clear maybe I'm we can give the
shot here so it is actually two
completely lost yeah I wasn't seeing a
direct win okay the computer just plays
rook fe1 and intense eform yeah you can
kick you can you don't get away from
here anymore it's just so bad on evade
okay so Rukia diem that was the correct
one and exactly after Quincy to night FA
ATM that line is also mentioned night h5
is mentioned as a move where is the move
from the game and then actually b5 was
played
and black was fine and ultimately one
probably also because the hoviak is a
good I am if I remember correctly and I
don't know the white player maybe black
was also the better player there but
yeah so I got his right just looking at
potential ideas that white may have and
then I spotted the Queen c2 idea and
found rook e8 as a good prophylaxis this
is how it works yeah you want to make a
move that is useful in some way or
creators are useful move and you want to
address what the opponent does actually
you look at the engine finds it as well
okay so we can switch it off yeah okay
so let's have a look at the second
position that is from the games as a
Kieran Rosen tireless Warsaw Organa
polish game warsaw 2008 so and I don't
know the position or the game this is
for white
so let's put this on
you
yeah I wonder if that was a takane's
defense
roseann TARDIS is opening it looks a
little bit like it
I'm sorry
now could be many openings actually
okay
Queen
now is that right let's check King yes
like hisses
or the piece of staff
yeah I think the position is correct
okay it's white to play orientation
white and create chapter now so it's
right to move and yeah a fairly common
structure we have this pawn center that
often arises from the caro-kann
Scandinavian defense the Alekhine's
sometimes it can also happen from from a
Slav defense yeah when TNT porn it
traded now we know that it is
prophylaxis so what could be blacks idea
here what is our idea
interesting
you
you
but
this is interesting that black has the
rooks like that
maybe he just wants to check e5 and I
can ID five pawn takes e5 90 d7
I would still think that white should be
with better them
mm not sure maybe or c5 maybe black
might play c5
mmm yeah that is probably what black
wants to do
to c5 I mean if black plays c5 and if we
don't have anything good against us is
probably going to equalize um one
important point is that you would
usually want to play d5 against c5 so
I'm just making a monkey and adjust one
something like that
so you would like to do this which
currently would just blunder the night
this also brings us to a potential
point of this position
maybe we need to play in a way that
after c5 d5 is actually possible that is
not so easy to do
for example let's say we play rook e1
I've d5 we need to yeah black can take
everything now only five and
probably enough to discourage this but
can also take and then use this efile
situation
Oh sting
you
hmm now how do we react to a c5
I don't think
yeah I wanted to say I don't think c5
can be right
you
[Music]
now I don't think this can be right
like black does not have a light squared
bishop anymore that would be a different
story of her Bishop is on c8 for black
and maybe one of ours on g2 or on c2 or
something but this this shouldn't be
really good
also I would be surprised to learn that
night XG sex is something that looks are
too harmless
mm interesting
absolutely not sure
we could also
go age five its position
basically force black to take this is
also interesting
like this
you
yeah it doesn't look too convincing to
me
if I would get to d6 maybe but I don't
quite see how this would work
and let's say after takes takes e5 is
pretty weekend
I don't think f4 is a good idea
something like f1 + f6 it can easily
blow up to my face yeah the King on g1
is completely open huh okay I don't
really have an idea
currently how to handle this
maybe again c5 we have to take on g6 and
then play d5
okay that could be an idea so let's say
I play rookie one
see 596 pawn takes and d5
now yeah that could be interesting now
if he takes with the pawn and we are
threatening to take on his ex which is a
bit awkward so if he takes us we can
take f6
that is probably quite good for white
looks very good actually 95
yeah I'm not sure if I'm mediately
winning but it must be close to that
thread simply to take and double on the
eighth-ranked the rooks are much
stronger than the Queen iam so that is
interesting after d5 here black more or
less as to move the bishop
Bishop d6
you can maybe take a plane
that looks kind of good okay maybe maybe
this is right Ruki one so that after c5
we can take and play d5 that could be an
idea I don't really see much else to be
honest in this kind of position if we
play rook e1 and black takes we take
here actually we have the advantage
compared to an earlier examined line
that the pawn is still here so I don't
have to now attend to the cover of the
g5 Bishop I could actually just draw it
back
in play
idea
but even also even the CAPTCHA is better
now than it was before for sure and this
is this could be a bit better for what
if four is stronger than it was
performed but there are a couple of
things that I could try here
oh no you're not entirely certain how
how to do this
I would like to play 90 46 okay but I
think Wright is a bit better here anyway
so I don't need to we don't need to find
something super conclusive here I would
I would think rookie one is an idea just
to make sure that c5 is not hitting us
yeah I'm going to check this now I don't
again I don't want to make forever with
every position
so no h5 is right ok so I missed
something there h5
[Music]
yeah in the game you see em the book
says that in the game room a d1 was
played after which c5 equalized yeah
okay this is not rocket science and we
found that out so I would like to know
okay we can shake rook e1 a bit later
but so h1 is correct it seems so I must
have missed something here because I
couldn't find something good he end this
is the case the MOOC with the moves look
a d1 is very strong yeah that is true
yeah once you get this here basic claim
ma'am
now we are threatening this and Knight
takes Bishop f4 is pretty awful yeah
this is a really cool kind of position
white as a decisive advantage shell I
believe that
afonya the queen where is it here like
just running out of moves quickly yeah
that's indeed terrible so I missed I
missed this resource through 81
I'm sorry look 81m okay
in the game bishop know that top the
game net so bishop takes you five this
is how it continues and why it is not
better yeah okay we believe that i think
so
it's rupee one a bad move so let's check
if my idea if that also made some sense
okay it seems to be the second best move
at least yeah
h5 is a huge advantage plus 1.9 and
rookie one at least is plus one so and
this is not as good but probably it at
least stop c5 so I think c5 I wanted to
take okay h5 is better even but I wanted
to take and g5 is indeed a huge
advantage so okay so at least managed to
prevent blacks main idea which which is
as a Kieran kale to do they look 81 c5
is this is sloppy this is a bit sloppy
to allow c5 in this position so and this
is actually I think reasonably clear but
this is not so easy really that because
here you kind of automatically think
okay you have to do something with the
bishop and in fact you don't there you
have this very strong yeah in some way
intermediate moves mmm nice yeah but a
good exercise that's a good exercise
okay the third one is the game royce
nickel off
put this on the board
that's for whites oh okay
this is slightly
more simplified position
many pieces on the world
which doesn't necessarily mean it's easy
we all know how tricky
here porn endings can be
okay we definitely need a king on g1 so
I think this is the position three six
six
that right yes okay so
white player yeah okay okay I think
shoot
I have to do it again I'm sorry
I wanted to I had to switch off the
engine I don't want to I don't want to
put it on the board and then all of the
engine immediately tells me what's right
but okay this this is not
not so many pieces some
you
okay I think this is a position
yeah looks good why to play and create
chapter so we did not get now spoiler
tear with them with the engine there
okay so why tear has the more active
position we have some pressure here
against the king of course with this
rook is currently stopped here on the C
file so what could be Lex ID n
disposition
interesting did it doesn't really look
like a position where black a
threatening all that much I mean after
all a black cannot move the rook the
king any of those pawns
so not that much that he can move
ah I think I think I've got an idea what
black is threatening here at least um
let's say I mean you can sometimes just
reverse it and they were what would
black do ever this blacks move
maybe blacks idea is just to play Bishop
e7 attacking our queen and then possibly
Bishop f6 yeah that could be an idea
for example let's say I'm sure but what
a non move is here let's say I'm playing
this which is kind of stupid of course
but just to show ya the queen is
attacked probably will go to h5 and then
maybe even though the the pawn structure
is severely compromised maybe still this
move because after the trade there's an
immediate oops
Treach on g2 and this is some kind of
counter flier now this and this is
threatened
obviously rue k1 is utterly stupid but
it could be yeah this this this idea
could be possible
still sounds a little bit odd
to try to prevent
it should be seven in this position
and how how do we actually make some
headway here
progress not not easy
hmm not easy to same there anything else
that black could maybe do move like a
five certainly helpful maybe to stop any
before
you
ah so any other threat
gnorm
don't really see all that much black
could do here that B should be seven
idea yeah again maybe a five but
yet how do I ever activate the rook here
mmm
you
sorry for them for the long thing I just
tried to get a grasp of this and that
don't quite see him even an idea that
it's not much right I've seen an idea
but I am very unsure that this ever
would do much my ideas GE form that's
something that just came to my mind
that's not very prophylactic in some way
it is as Bishop b725 is definitely a
point
my idea here was simply to play like
this and just claim that the Queen trade
would be favorable for white and I think
this is a correct claim this is
definitely nice yeah we can play rook t1
or some pressure King g2 and the
diagonal is pretty good so this is this
is certainly a poor for white
it is not clear I mean black also
probably doesn't want to allow the
capture and rock t1
I actually like this I mean GOI it's not
a bad
idea as far as I can see
you know that seems like a really tough
prophylactic
chief all
one thing that it addresses is the
strong position of blacks Queen the
queen is blacks best piece head
centralized cannot easily be attacked
and it always helps with ideas like f4
or sometimes d4 so they are dear to with
this play trying to trade the Queen's
it's not bad I don't think it's bad if
black tries to keeps the Queen on we can
play
Laurie disruptive one
but maybe even putting a rook on the G
file isn't totally stupid a king edge
one rupee one hmm
I kind of like G form it it would be a
bit odd if this is a solution
another move that I like is Queen age
five
idea to play it's just this Queen f3 and
now B should be seven I can probably
play okay rook c7s Queen B one
but this is this is not much of a deal
anyway I can I can play queen of three
the bishop is here we are always ready
to enter we cannot enter now here
because this is just too annoying
Queen age five - orgy for these moves
really attract me
tough run disease are tough tough
exercises but looking at positions like
that and really trying to figure out
what's going on is helpful it just helps
to improve your thinking process I'm
going to check it I'm going to look it
up I don't want your 45 minutes worth my
time goal for this type of video so no I
didn't get it right at all
the solution is h4 interesting
ah
okay I'm
yeah this shows you one of my problems
in chess and sometimes don't see
technical points the move Bishop e7 is
not an idea at all it's not an idea at
all because I can simply checkmate like
yeah I can it's just made
can give up a couple of pieces but it's
made
so this is not the threat okay but what
is age four prophylactic against maybe
the maybe I was too much irritated by
the subject by the by the by the by the
steam
Oh
hmm
the idea of h4 is very clear I we just
want to push over the way to h6 and
black cannot stop us this is an cute
maid
interesting
yeah then what was Black's idea then
what is age for prophylaxis against
I don't know it looks like a strong move
I admit that okay so what does the
engine say let's see what what the
computer gives him yeah after a little
bit of back and forth it comes up with
h4i but g4 is the second best or a third
best move so at least I'm not talking
complete nonsense g4 is there's number
three at least
yeah but this is strong quite kitty if
you can push all the way up deform we
can just take a couple of times and then
take a five right yeah Bishop takes
orange eggs and you take them home
yeah okay so h4 is strong hmm no su as
you saw I mean I'm doing this real time
I never crossed my mind
but the problem was really that Bishop
b7 was not an idea or I should have
spotted the tactic
I mean I would have been more puzzled
even then because if that is not an idea
what idea to supply actually have I mean
I was referring to d4 and f4 and this is
how I came up with g4 so this is what
happens after g4
I think I'm correct in the assumption
that the Queen trade is pretty good for
us and I said this is a good ending out
suck plus one sounds reasonable
yeah I'm like a sitting on a couple of
weaknesses g5 and the King is not
helping here we am quickly activating so
as I said the Queen will probably
retreat to e7 and then h4 okay this was
not part of my part of my set of ideas
at all to push the edge pawn did
actually I didn't look at a movie um
yeah yeah I mean I'm quite positive that
white is a bit better here like rook t1
something like that but I didn't quite
figure it out yeah so H form was clearly
stronger and you should really see that
Bishop e7 that's not a move which is a
bit awful that I didn't see Queen g7
it's not exactly the most difficult
tactic here hmm interesting interesting
I didn't didn't quite get it right but
I'm kind of okay with the result yeah
I've got one completely right and I
spotted some good ideas you have to be
if you do really difficult exercises
like that you can access you can
actually not expect to solve them all
it's not really it's possible sure if
you give that to Magnus he would solve
probably almost everything but like for
a normal person here if you get a couple
of a couple of them right and if you had
good ideas and ideas that are not really
totally raw farik I'm not too unhappy
with g-form I mean if I played this in a
game I will probably stop keep pressure
and set problems it's not a totally
stupid move yeah or the rook in one in
the game before it's also not completely
completely off yeah and this is also
to kind of sometimes check your ideas
not not only against the solutions that
an author gives you but also against the
computer I think it's still somewhat
comforting to know that okay h4 was
better and we didn't quite understand
everything but the move that I was
suggesting wasn't totally totally
terrible okay guys I hope you enjoyed
the video I will probably I'll be back
tomorrow probably with another tea
session thanks a lot for watching